Congratulations, you've reached
the end of this course.
Like an otter,
you too can rock the shell.
>> Now you're ready to go on to any
number of subjects that depend on
the command line interface.
If you're interested in running Linux
servers, take a look at out Linux for
web developers course.
>> Another command line
tool to learn is Git.
A very popular distributed
version control system.
We have a course on that too.
We put links to these courses, and other
resources in the instructors notes and
in the course wiki.
>> And do come back to the discussion
forums to share your questions, and
your discoveries
>> We hope you enjoyed this course.
See you next time.